وسط كهرمان مرعش يحاول فاروق استرجاع ما
امكنه من سلع كان يعرضها في محله الذي
حوله الزلزال الى ركام
هذا الشارع كان تجاريا بامتياز وكنت امتلك
محلا لبيع السجاد من اربعه طوابق لكن
الزلزال قضى على كل شيء ولا اعلم كيف ومتى
ساعود لعمل مجددا
الكارثه التي اودت بحياه عشرات الالاف
خلفت كذلك ركودا اقتصاديا في الولايات
الجنوبيه للبلاد وحولت مواطنيها الناجين
الى حياه البطاله والعيش على المساعدات
حاليا اصبحت عاطلا عن العمل كما تشاهد
السوق وكل المحلات اصبحت ركاما حتى وان
اردت العوده الى تجاره فلن استطيع لاني لم
اعد املك شيئا
الزلزال ومثل ما دمر اليابسه وما عليها في
الجنوب التركي لحقت اضراره البحر كذلك
ومست الميناء حسب اقتصاد المنطقه ومصدر
قوت اهاليها ميناء اسكندرون بهاتاي لحقته
اضرار زلزال واوقفت نشاط صياديه
نفس الشكل كلهم كسر كله ما بنعرف كيف بدنا
نعمل شو بده يصير فينا تقرير للبنك الدولي
قدر اضرار الزلزال باربعه
فيما يرجح اقتصاديون تجاوز هذا الرقم
بكثير اما السلطات التركيه فدخلت في سباق
مع الزمن لاحتواء الازمه والتبعاتها عبد
القادر خربوش العربيه جنوب تركيا